escasos eeuu aumenta su presencia
militar en europa del este la
administración de joe biden anunció que
enviará a 3.000 soldados en la región
para prepararla contra posibles ataques
en medio de la concentración de
alrededor de 100.000 tropas rusas en la
frontera con ucrania del total 2 mil
soldados saldrán de la base fort bragg
carolina del norte 1700 de ellos para
polonia y 300 para alemania otras 1.000
tropas apostadas hoy en la base de
estadounidense débil sé que en alemania
serán relocalizadas en rumanía
que son no son movimientos permanentes
responden a condiciones actuales
ajustaremos nuestra postura según la
evolución de esas condiciones todos
estos efectivos son separados y
adicionales a las 8 mil 500 tropas en
eeuu en alerta elevada que ya no se la
semana pasada
el kremlin que niega que vaya a invadir
a ucrania calificó la medida como un
paso destructivo que refuerza la
atención militar en europa mientras
tanto más voces se suman al llamado a
evitar un conflicto bélico después de
visitar quiere el martes el primer
ministro británico boris johnson
insistió telefónicamente al mandatario
ruso vladimir putin en la necesidad de
encontrar una solución diplomática
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón y
el canciller alemán olaf scholz también
hablarán con el líder ruso los esfuerzos
para llegar a una solución pacífica han
fallado y las partes se mantienen firmes
en sus posiciones moscú exige entre
otros que la otan le prohíba a quien su
adhesión al organismo una petición que
para occidente es imposible de cumplir